bart's much more impulsive uh than his
than his father and
and that's a strength for bart in his
mind
what did i miss dad meet your son bart
i'm so excited jordan welcome to the
flash family
i am so thrilled and you are stepping
into the west allen family which has
arguably the most passionate fans
i have ever encountered what is it like
coming into the one of the most beloved
tv families of all time that is yeah i
was putting it mildly
i mean like yeah the show's been going
for a minute people have grown up with
this show people have like
met loves of their lives watching the
show and have gotten married
and had kids since and like that's this
is comfort this is comfort
it's exciting grant and candace are in
everyone's homes every tuesday night
and that is a special and for the last
seven years right like that's that's a
that's a big deal it's a really really
big deal we saw
in in previous seasons that nora is a
bit of a daddy's girl
mm-hmm would you say that bart is a
mama's boy
yeah yeah i would definitely say so
definitely so
for sure all the candice fans are
freaking out right now by the way by
that answer
oh my god well and also candace and i
just
a dory like it was instant
it was instant we just looked at each
other like
all right we down right we we hit it we
get it hey dad
what's good or pops can i call you pops
yet you like it when i call you pops
later i can't remember when that is
stuff
but as bart and as barry you get to see
a little bit more similarity between my
father and son yeah which is
like that's fun to explore still a very
different person
bart's much more impulsive uh than his
than his father
and and that's a strength for bart in
his mind um
that's a strength his impulsivity and
the fact that no one can
determine what he's going to do because
he doesn't even know what he's going to
do yet
is a real that's that's like an added
superpower
to be honest with you it is an advantage
in the timeline too
yeah and so that's what he thinks yeah
that's what bart thinks that's what
maybe a couple other people in bart's
life thinks but
barry doesn't agree with that barry
doesn't think that way also
that's we're talking about his son like
no dad's gonna just like let
her kid just go yeah until their kid
just decides you know what
don't care and does it anyway and
uh that that's that's a really fun
dynamic to explore especially because
grant and i are friends
seeing you in the pose from the front of
the comic book like so great take me
back to that moment jordan
the first time you put on bart's suit
what was your initial reaction oh it's
insane i mean you know the lead up to
all of that's
a lot right so as a person i'm already a
nerd and a big comic book fan and
superhero fan of course i've always
ended as an actor for
as long as i've been doing it i've
always wanted to play superhero of
course i might have so many photos and
videos on my phone of me getting the
suit on for the first time it was
unbelievable it's exactly what you kind
of imagined it to feel like
bart does things that other speedsters
don't do bart the way the bart moves and
how he fights how he runs how he skids
in and out of things um
is all very very different so it it was
important to me
that i have as much movement and
flexibility as possible
and um you know thankfully we have an
amazing team and they were down to keep
making adjustments
for me until it got to a place where i
was like all right
like we're good let's let's keep it
going let's keep it going yo
this place is crash
where did the the catchphrase this is so
crash come from
hmm that's just that's all bart lingo
man i love it
yeah those kind of those are comic book
days that's uh that's the things are
different
in the future you know we have different
phrases and we dress differently and we
function differently and you know bart
bart is unapologetically himself and
we'll
carry himself anywhere he is and and uh
it's fun is
just very very important to me that
we have as much young justice
comic booky stuff that people can be
like oh i
did that i think he did it he said he
said the thing that's really cool but
let it also be completely
separate i i did all of the research
that a human being could do
on bart and on impulse and have come up
with my own concoction of all the things
that i like about bart
in different iterations and different
versions of him and made
my version of him for
this for live action and if it's
received well and if people like what
i'm doing with the role and it makes
sense
and people would be happy to you know
see if something continue
that's something i would always be down
to explore for sure it just has to be it
has to be
real it has to be organic and not forced
i'm the
i'm the first person to be like this
doesn't feel
good i'm a bounce
if you could go back and revisit one of
your previous characters for a new
project who would you pick
oh to revisit an old character for a new
project that's
interesting huh
i think the the to all the boys fans
would be curious to know
what happens for these characters
15 years later and i mean hey there's
ideas of a to all the boys series
spin-off
so we could see that would be fun that
could be really cool too that could be
cool
um yeah i mean i think that would be a
lot of fun frankly impulse would be
really
i'm curious as to you know what kind of
life impulse could have outside of the
flash
you know the dc world is a very very big
world so i'm here i'm just curious
and also i have to say congratulations
you tied the knot
less than a year ago i'm so excited for
you
how is newlywed life for you and your
lovely wife ellie the best
yeah it really is the best it is that
marriage is highly recommended 10 out of
10
uh especially if it's your best friend
and that's
that that's really what it is i mean we
were 9 and 13 years old when we met
you know so we grew up best friends we
were we were she was like a little
sister to me growing up and then like
you know we hit college age and we were
like living our lives and doing our
things we were you know
still really good friends and keep up
with each other and whatnot and then
um you know years later she was in
college for the university of alabama
for nutrition and then i was working on
hamilton in new york and
was like what come up and see the show
let's come up and see the show let's see
what happens and we got dinner and
we kept getting dinner and then
eventually i was like hey you want to
date me
when i have all of our dinners yeah and
then she was and then i was like hey you
want to marry me
and then you want to make babies with me
like you want to have a family
is that a plan like like what is next in
your love journey
yeah we would definitely we we
definitely want to start a family
that's that is the that's the goal we
have a big big big family we're both
from the south
so we want we want a slew of them
running around
and dogs and cats we want a zoo we won
the whole
house full of chaos i want someone to be
coming in here with a sippy cup right
now asking me a question i may have to
tell them to go ask mom like
we want we love that kind of dynamic we
both grew up around a lot of that and so
we to us
we're we're happiest when we have people
in our home and
so the idea of having like like our own
our tribe you know rolling deep
everywhere that just sounds like a blast
oh my gosh yeah